Тут, на кордоні України з Білоруссю, за вами завжди стежать.
Наш. Це наші дрони. Проводимо аеророзвідку.
Може бути й по-іншому. Для місцевих українських прикордонників
війна 24 лютого почалася з атаки російського безпілотника з іншого боку кордону.
Вони намагалися стримати просування російських військ з Білорусі й підірвали цей міст.
Але російська армія все одно прийшла і затрималася в регіоні майже на місяць.
У квітні російські війська відвели від Києва. Відтоді стрілянина
тут здебільшого обмежується навчаннями - з обох боків кордону.
Чимало українців побоюються, що російські навчання в Білорусі
можуть знову перерости у військове вторгнення, як це було в лютому.
Російські війська повністю так і не залишили Білорусь. На білоруських полігонах
постійно тривають військові навчання. Українське керівництво
тривалий час говорило, що не бачить загрози нового вторгнення з боку Білорусі.
Ми віримо в те, що Білорусь не втягнеться в цю війну.
Але провокації є, провокації будуть. Ми розуміємо, що це не рішення білоруського народу.
І ми вважаємо, що білоруському народу треба робити все, щоб не втягнутися в цю війну.
Але останнім часом чисельність російських військ на кордоні збільшилася,
а тон білоруського правителя Олександра Лукашенка став більш агресивним.
Якщо тільки ви наважитеся нанести удар, як планується, по Гомелю на півдні,
по Мозирському нафтопереробному заводу, по аеродрому в Лунинці чи по Бресту
- відповідь буде миттєвою. Миттєвою, просто в одну секунду.
Чим відповісти у нас є. Ви повністю перебуваєте під ударом цих ракет.
Ситуація залишається напруженою по обидва боки українсько-білоруського кордону.
На цих відео, як стверджує білоруська сторона, українські підрозділи
мінують свій бік кордону.
Кордон між Україною та Білоруссю розтягнувся більш ніж на 1000 кілометрів.
До війни більша частина кордону була позначена, але не укріплена.
Поїздки за кордон по продукти чи до лікаря тут були звичною справою.
Родичі ж є і в Росії, і всюди, спілкувалися, їхні люди приїжджали до нас,
наші їздили туди. Ніколи не думали, що таке станеться.
Ніхто не знає, що у них у голові, що вони там собі думають.
Тепер кордон помітний і на місцевості, і в людських стосунках.
Багато в кого із нашого села родичі і в Жарах, і в Гомелі жили люди,
спілкувалися. А зараз є такі, що спілкуються, а є такі що й ні.
Але ми віримо, що буде перемога. Буде, інакше просто не може бути.
Хоча російські війська з 24 лютого використовують Білорусь
як плацдарм для обстрілів України, повноцінна участь Мінська у війні
- відкрите питання. Експерти радять не покладатися в цьому питанні
на публічні заяви Олександра Лукашенка.
Риторика Лукашенка - неоднозначна. Тому що він також заявляє,
що це не наша війна. На мою думку, нині ми не можемо знати напевне,
що це значить. Лукашенко може демонструвати Путіну свою солідарність
і готовність воювати, але при цьому уникати використання білоруської армії.
Або ж це може бути поступове втягнення Білорусі у війну.
Білорусь протягом останніх п'яти місяців продовжує військові навчання
у прикордонних регіонах і розпочинає нові. Утім, політичний експерт
і білорус за походженням Ігор Тишкевич вважає такі кроки радше демонстраційними,
аніж ознаками реальної загрози. Хоча, на думку фахівця, такі маневри
білоруської армії значно обмежують дії ЗСУ.
Якщо українська армія тримає достатньо великі резерви на кордоні з Білоруссю,
а кордон - це все ж таки 800 з гаком кілометрів, то звісно, що ці війська і техніка
не потрапляють на фронт.
Соцопитування в Білорусі демонструють небажання білорусів воювати.
Дослідження білоруської ініціативи Chatham House і Білоруської аналітичної майстерні
у червні показали схожі результати: понад 80 відсотків громадян країни
проти участі білоруської армії у війні проти України, а підтримка дій Росії падає.
І саме це не дає Лукашенку можливості передати білоруську армію
в розпорядження Путіна. Адже це може стати його політичним крахом.
Та й думка людей, які становлять основу режиму Лукашенка,
не надто відрізняється від суспільної думки - що це не війна білорусів,
і що участь Білорусі в ній непотрібна.
Водночас час від часу російські війська, які перебувають у Білорусі, активізуються.
За повідомленням моніторингової групи "Білоруський Гаюн",
останніми днями на білоруських аеродромах зросла активність
транспортної авіації. Крім того, за домовленостями Путіна і Лукашенка,
найближчими місяцями Білорусь отримає від Росії ракетні комплекси "Іскандер-М",
які здатні нести ядерний заряд.
Експерт Ігор Тишкевич відзначає, що Білорусь і надалі залишатиметься
плацдармом для російської армії, адже цілком залежить від Москви
у зовнішній політиці. Як приклад, експерт наводить ситуацію
з масовим ракетним обстрілом України з території Білорусі наприкінці червня,
якому передували спроби Мінська налагодити експорт зерна з України
білоруською територією.
Білоруське МЗС розпочало спроби консультацій з державами насамперед ЄС
- а що робити, як виходити з цього кута. Частина західних партнерів
не повірили Лукашенку, йому не вірять, але вони почали розглядати варіант
- "окей, а може, ми спробуємо"? У цей самий момент "а може ми спробуємо"
Лукашенко летить до Путіна, російські літаки залітають у Білорусі і стріляють.
Тепер будь-хто з цих політиків у здоровому глузді не буде говорити: "А може ми спробуємо?"
Росія суттєво знизила поле для маневру Лукашенка. Це як, знаєте, собака на повідку.
Він забіг далеко - смик і повернув.
Голова української розвідки Кирило Буданов в одному з інтерв'ю
назвав кількість російських військ у Білорусі мізерною.
Водночас у Генштабі не виключають провокацій з боку Білорусі.
Тим часом в українських селах поблизу білоруського кордону
чимало жителів залишили свою роботу й стали до лав територіальної оборони.
Є охоронець, є водії, є продавці, є слюсарі.
Життя Костянтина змінилося в одну мить. Його призвали до армії,
тепер він керує десятками людей в теробороні. Хлопець ніколи не воював.
Весь його досвід - військова підготовка в університеті.
Більшість не розуміють, навіть ті області, які не зачепило це все, вони не знають,
як це, коли ти бачиш свою дитину, а вона боїться всього.
Якщо наприклад 23-го в тебе ще не було такої агресії, не міг навіть на людину руку підняти,
то, наприклад, 24-го всі хлопці уже знали, що якщо прийде противник,
то вони будуть діяти як одне ціле. І ніхто не буде сумніватися.
Атмосфера тут може здатися розслабленою та домашньою - сусіди і навіть батьки
та сини служать пліч-о-пліч. Але почуття загрози, що насувається, не відпускає.
Костянтин каже, що йому, на щастя, ще не доводилося повідомляти сім'ям
про загибель близьких, але він не впевнений, що так буде й надалі.